I'M JOHN BERMAN WITH BRIANNA
KEILAR.
ON THIS "NEW DAY," FROM GALLOWS
TO GASLIGHT.
DEVELOPING OVERNIGHT, MIKE
PENCE, HISTORY BOY.
HE WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF HISTORY
ON JANUARY 6th, THE DAY
INSURRECTIONISTS WERE CHANTING,
"HANG MIKE PENCE."
THEY WERE YELLING TO KILL HIM IN
ORDER TO OVERTHROW AN ELECTION.
DONALD TRUMP AND THE RIOTERS
WANTED HIM TO UNILATERALLY DEFY
THE ELECTION RESULTS.
MIKE PENCE REFUSED TO UPEND
DEMOCRACY THAT DAY, THOUGH HE
HAD TO RUN IT BY DAN QUAYLE
FIRST.
THAT IS THE HISTORY, KNOWN TO
ALL WHO SAW IT AND ALL THOSE WHO
HAVE WRITTEN ON IT, INCLUDING
BOB WOODWARD AND ROBERT COSTA'S
"IN PERIL."
IN A HISTORICAL AND MORAL
CONTORTION, MIKE PENCE IS TRYING
TO REDIRECT THE BLAME FOR THE
INSURRECTION.
>> I KNOW THE MEDIA WANTS TO
DISTRACT FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S FAILED AGENDA
BY FOCUSING ON ONE
JANUARY.
THEY WANT TO USE THE ONE DAY TO
TRY TO DEMEAN THE CHARACTER AND
INTENTIONS OF 74 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO BELIEVED WE COULD
BE STRONG AGAIN AND PROSPEROUS
AGAIN AND SUPPORTED OUR
ADMINISTRATION IN 2016 AND 2020.
>> PENCE TELLING IT LIKE IT
ISN'T.
AGAIN, FROM GALLOWS TO GASLIGHT.
THE MEDIA WASN'T CHANTING, "HANG
MIKE PENCE."
THE INSURRECTIONISTS WERE.
THE PEOPLE THERE TO OVERTURN THE
RESULTS OF AN ELECTION, TO
IGNORE THE WILL OF 81 MILLION
VOTERS, AND DO WORSE TO HIM.
>> HANG MIKE PENCE!
HANG MIKE PENCE!
>> PENCE GOES ON TO TALK ABOUT
HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH TRUMP.
>> YOU CAN'T SPEND ALMOST FIVE
YEARS IN A POLITICAL FOX HOLE
WITH SOMEBODY WITHOUT DEVELOPING
A STRONG RELATIONSHIP.
YOU KNOW, JANUARY 6th WAS A
TRAGIC DAY IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
CAPITOL BUILDING.
BUT THANKS TO THE EFFORTS OF
CAPITOL HILL POLICE, FEDERAL
OFFIALS, THE CAPITOL WAS
SECURED.
WE FINISHED OUR WORK.
THE PRESIDENT AND I SAT DOWN A
FEW DAYS LATER AND TALKED
THROUGH ALL OF IT.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE PARTED
AMICABLY.
>> WHAT PART OF ALL THIS DO YOU
THINK THEY CALLED THROUGH
EXACTLY?
HOW TRUMP WANTED TO USE PENCE AS
THE CENTERPIECE FOR HIS
ATTEMPTED COUP?
MAYBE THEY TALKED ABOUT WHAT
TRUMP SAID AT THE STEEL RALLY.
>> MIKE PENCE IS GOING TO HAVE
TO COME THROUGH FOR US.
IF HE DOESN'T, THAT WILL BE A
SAD DAY FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> MAYBE THEY TALKED THROUGH THE
TWEET THAT TRUMP SENT DURING THE
BREACH OF THE CAPITOL DURING THE
BREACH, WHERE TRUMP SAID THAT
PENCE DIDN'T HAVE THE COURAGE TO
PROTECT THE COUNTRY.
>> JOINING US NOW, SENIOR MEDIA
REPORTER OLIVER DARBY AND
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR ESSE CUPP.
THIS WAS A PROBABLE FOR THE
CAPITOL BUILDING ON JANUARY 6th.
>> IT IS GRADING TO ME, THE WAY
HE CONTINUES TO TALK ABOUT
JANUARY 6th AS IF IT HAPPENED TO
HIM OR, LIKE, AROUND HIM.
AS IF HE WASN'T A PART OF HOW WE
GOT HERE.
LOOK, THE PEOPLE WHO GOT UP THAT
DAY AND CHOSE VIOLENCE, RIGHT,
CHOSE TO COMMIT A CRIME AT THE
CAPITOL, DID SO FOR DONALD
TRUMP, BUT THERE WAS A WHOLE
APPARATUS THAT GOT THOSE PEOPLE
THERE.
THE APPARATUS INCLUDED SOME
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS, SOME
RIGHT-WING MEDIA, AND MIKE PENCE
WAS PART OF THAT APPARATUS, TOO.
SO IT'S VERY CONFOUNDING TO
WATCH HIM DEFLECT AND ACT AS IF
THIS WAS AN EVENT IN HISTORY
THAT HE WAS REMOVED FROM.
>> IT WAS A MEDIA PROBLEM.
>> WHAT ISN'T, REALLY, TODAY?
I MEAN, IF YOU ASK A REPUBLICAN,
IT'S ALL OUR FAULT.
WE'VE DONE IT ALL.
>> WHEN ALL ELSE FAILS,
ATTACKING THE MEDIA IS THE
EASIEST THING FOR THESE GUYS P.
OBVIOUSLY, PENCE HAS NO OTHER
WAY TO EXPLAIN THIS AWAY, SO HE
PI
PIVOTS IN THE INTERVIEW WITH
HANNITY.
HANNITY IS USED TO ATTACKING THE
PRESS, AND THEY BOTH SEEM TO USE
THAT AS A WAY TO MOVE ON.
>> THE RECORD IS WHAT THE RECORD
IS.
AS I SAID, THE HISTORY IS THE
HISTORY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER, TO AN EXTENT,
WHAT HE SAYS ABOUT JANUARY 6th
FOR JANUARY 6th'S SAKE.
IT MATTERS FOR NOW.
IT MATTERS FOR WHAT IS BEING
DONE WITH IT NOW IN GOING
FORWARD, S.E.
WHY DOES THIS MATTER?
>> FIRST, THE WHOLE THING SOUNDS
A LITTLE DELUSIONAL.
NOT JUST THE WAY HE TALKS ABOUT
JANUARY 6th BUT PARTING AMICABLY
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TRASHING
HIM.
HE MIGHT BE SAYING, WE'RE IN A
GOOD PLACE, BUT, PER USUAL, THE
LOYALTY FLOWS ONE WAY.
TRUMP IS NOT RETURNING THE
FAVOR.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, IF MIKE
PENCE IS TRYING TO STAY ON
TRUMP'S GOOD SIDE -- WELL, YOU
HAVE TO BE THERE TO BEGIN WITH,
WHICH HE IS NOT.
WHAT IS THIS FOR?
DOES HE WANT TO RAISE MONEY?
DOES HE WANT INFLUENCE?
DOES HE THINK HE'S RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT ONE DAY?
THERE ARE NO NATURAL MIKE PENCE
VOTERS.
THERE ARE THOSE WHO FELT
BETRAYED, LIKE ME.
SOME LOYALISTS WON'T EVER TRUST
MIKE PENCE.
WHO IS CLAMORING FOR MORE MIKE
PENCE?
THIS STRATEGY, IF YOU CAN CALL
IT ONE, MAKES VERY LITTLE SENSE
TO ME.
>> THAT'S WHY HE IS ON
"HANNITY," RIGHT?
HE IS COURTING THOSE FOLKS THAT
HE DOESN'T, AS YOU SAY -- WHO IS
THE CONSTITUENCY HERE.
HE IS TRYING.
BUT IN A LOGICAL WORLD, WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IS TRUMP WOULD
APOLOGIZE TO PENCE, RIGHT,
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED.
>> YOU MEAN ON EARTH.
>> HERE ON EARTH.
>> EARTH ONE, NOT EARTH TWO.
>> ON EARTH TWO, IT'S THE OTHER
WAY.
IT IS MIKE PENCE, AS SO MANY
REPUBLICANS WHO DECIDED TO BREAK
WITH DONALD TRUMP A LITTLE BIT
AROUND THE INSURRECTION, HE'S
NOW SUCKING UP.
HE'S ON THE FULL SUCK UP MODE.
>> RIGHT.
WHAT HE'S SAYING ACTUALLY DOES
MAKE SOME SENSE IF YOU WATCH
RIGHT-WING MEDIA.
IN RIGHT-WING MEDIA, JANUARY 6th
WASN'T AN INSURRECTION.
IT HAS BEEN PORTRAYED AS, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE JUST GOING TO THE
CAPITOL, SEEING THINGS, AND
POLICE TAKING SELFIES WITH THE
PROTECTERS OR, YOU KNOW, THAT'S
HOW IT IS BEING PORTRAYED IN
RIGHT-WING MEDIA.
SO FOR HIM TO GO ON THERE AND
DOWNPLAY IT MAKES SENSE IF HE
DOES WANT THAT FUTURE IN
REPUBLICAN POLITICS.
WHETHER HE ACTUALLY HAS ONE, YOU
KNOW, I TEND TO AGREE WITH S.E.
I DON'T SEE WHO THE NATURAL MIKE
PENCE VOTERS ARE.
BUT IT SEEMS HE IS TRYING TO
COURT THEM ON SEAN HANNITY'S
SHOW.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE TO GO ON
"HANNITY."
HE CAN RETREAT AND RETIRE TO
PRIVATE LIFE AND, PRETEND IN HIS
OWN MIND, HE WASN'T INVOLVED IN
ANY OF THIS.
HE IS ACTIVELY PURSUING THE
SPOTLIGHT AGAIN AND, AGAIN, I'M
NOT SURE WHY.
>> WHAT BOTHERS ME MOST IS
BIGGER THAN MIKE PENCE.
IF YOU SAY IT DIDN'T HAPPEN THE
WAY WE SAW IT HAPPEN, IF YOU SAY
IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT IT
HAPPENED, THEN WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS IT IS OKAY IF IT
HAPPENS AGAIN.
>> RIGHT.
>> THAT'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN
RIGHT NOW.
EVERYONE IS DUMBING DOWN HISTORY
SO MUCH, YOU ARE CREATING A
PERMISSION STRUCTURE FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> FOR SURE.
MOST INFURIATINGLY ABOUT MIKE
PENCE AND WHY HE IS A
DISAPPOINTING CHARACTER IN THIS
IS HE IS TRYING TO SPLIT THE
BABY.
HE HAS SAID THIS WAS A VERY DARK
DAY.
>> IN THE BUILDING.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
HE HAS LAMENTED WHAT HAPPENED.
HE SAID HE WAS PROUD TO CERTIFY
JOE BIDEN AS PRESIDENT.
SO HE IS TRYING TO KIND OF HAVE
IT BOTH WAYS.
ACKNOWLEDGING WHAT A LOT OF
TRUMP VOTERS ARE TALKING ABOUT
WILL NOT, WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENED
THAT DAY.
I'M NOT REALLY SURE WHAT THE
MASTER PLAN IS.
HE IS CONSTANTLY CONTRADICTING
HIMSELF.
>> IF YOU PAY ATTENTION TO THE
RIGHT-WING MEDIA WORLD, AFTER
JANUARY 6th, THERE WAS A LOT
MORE -- IN THE IMMEDIATE WAKE,
THERE WAS A LOT MORE OKAY
PERMISSION STRUCTURE TO SAY THAT
THIS WAS NOT GOOD AND CONDEMN
THESE PEOPLE.
BUT OVER THE PAST, WHAT, TEN
MONTHS, IT HAS REALLY BEEN
WATERED DOWN.
WHAT HAPPENED HAS SORT OF --
YOU'RE WATCHING TUCKER CARLSON,
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS, IT'S BEEN
WHITEWASHED, WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th.
NOW, MAYBE HE'S REALIZING, HEY,
IF I ACTUALLY DO WANT THIS
FUTURE IN REPUBLICAN POLITICS,
IT IS NO LONGER ACCEPTABLE TO
SAY WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT DAY.
YOU HAVE TO KIND OF EXCUSE IT
FOR, YOU KNOW -- EXCUSE THE
INSURRECTIONISTS.
>> IT'S DANGEROUS.
>> THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY'VE SHOWN NO INTEREST IN THE
WELL-BEING OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY'VE MADE UP EXCUSE AFTER
EXCUSE.
IT IS NOT A SURPRISE THEY'RE NOT
PAYING TO THE HEALTH OF SOCIETY.
>> PEOPLE FIXATE ON THE FACT
THAT, LIKE, THESE PEOPLE WERE
CALLING FOR MIKE PENCE TO BE
HANGED, RIGHT?
HOW CAN HE SORT OF, YOU KNOW,
RECONCILE THAT?
IF IT MAKES ANY SENSE, IT'S
WORSE.
THESE PEOPLE WERE CALLING FOR
THE DESTRUCTION OF AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
IT WASN'T JUST PERSONAL TO MAKE
IT AWFUL, IT WAS AWFUL FOR THE
COUNTRY.
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN ENOUGH
REASON FOR MIKE PENCE TOO.